Hey guys, I got a lot of information for you
and a few announcements that I know you're gonna be very excited about.
But first, I just wanted to say thank you.
And I don't say that enough, or I do say it enough and it's kind of lost its meaning.
I wrote a Tumblr blog about this, but you guys didn't have to read that.
Um, basically saying that...in the two years that I've been doing this,
I've said thank you so much, and it's never lost its meaning for me
and I don't ever want it to lose its meaning for you.
I don't ever want you to think that I'm just saying thank you just because I...want you guys to expect it,
or I think you guys want that from me, I'm saying it because I really and truly mean it.
Like, especially with all the new stuff that I've been trying to do for my channel
like, the amount of work that I put into editing each and every video has gone up tremendously
since just...a few months ago, like a six, seven minute video,
which may seem short to you, can take like 50 minutes of recording now
and...another two, three hours of editing it afterwards, you know.
I'm trying so many cool different things, and some of them may not seem cool to you
because, you know, I-I experiment with this one comedy cut that a lot of people didn't like
and then there's one that a lot of people really did like, but overall, the response has been absolutely amazing.
Like, absolutely incredible and I am so grateful that you guys are willing to join me
as I try to expand and improve on my videos. Um, especially with the Impossible Let's Play stuff.
Now, I know a lot of people - er, not a lot - but some people were like,
"Oh no, you're hurting yourself for views, we don't want this."
I would never do anything that actually puts me in harm's way.
Well, not permanent harm's way, anyway, but there's nothing wrong with doing a little challenge for a laugh.
And I would never go to the extreme lengths that some people were telling me to do,
but I always want to try to mix it up and do different things because I can't...myself, I can't just, uh,
repeat the same thing over and over, I can't just like, record a video, slap it up, and then throw it up on my channel
and expect, you know, ah, I'm just gonna rake in the views, no.
I-I what I want is I want to explore like, what I can really do
and how far I can push myself in terms of video making, and I'm just starting out,
even though I've been doing it two years, I'm just starting it out.
But I am so grateful that you guys have given me the opportunity to do this,
and you've given me the resources necessary to explore these different things that I can do
and collaborate with these amazing people that I am so honored to work with,
and...you know, it just means a lot to me that you guys are there for me every day.
And I don't say that enough, because the last time we did a vlog was three weeks ago
when we hit two million subscribers and now we're already at 2.2 million, and that is just amazing.
So thank you guys so much for everything that you've done for me.
Truly. Thank you.
Alright, onto the important informaton. You guys know I've been doing a lot of collabs since I got here,
well, there's gonna be even more in the near future. I'm so honored because a lot of these big YouTubers
that I've been following for a while suddenly want to work with me
and I'm so honored that they do and once again it's credit to you guys for pushing me to that point.
Um, so expect a lot more really cool collabs in the future and a lot of really interesting videos that I've been a part of
uh, like the Nacho Punch thing with the binge TV watching, that was amazingly fun
but there's even more coming in the near future, and most importantly!
May 6 to the 11th, my buddy Wade, his girlfriend Molly, Bob, my buddies from Cyndago, Daniel and Ryan
are all coming to LA to visit me for a five day stretch where we're just gonna go INSANE on making videos.
More Skate 3 with Bob, and a lot of games that you guys have been demanding me playing
but I have been intentionally saving them for this point where we can just through a smorgasboard of recording,
it's gonna be five days of nonstop stuff, it's gonna be so much fun,
I've been planning this forever, now I wanted to do a livestream while they were here
but I'm not set up for that, I literally have not had time,
if you look around anywhere off camera, it is still a mess, there's still trash and boxes,
I'm not set up to do a livestream, sadly. But what we are going to do is just going to make so many amazing videos
including sketch comedy videos, gameplay videos, montages, highlights, compilations, funny stuff,
everything you could possibly think of. I'm going to squeeze every little ounce of hilarity we can out of that short time
that we have together, so...and - and also just to be honest it'll be really good to see my friends again
because it has been a long time since I've been able to hang out with them.
I've been chatting with them online, texting them, but...um, you know,
I came out to LA and I've been working nonstop, every single moment of my life has been, you know,
all about work and I - I really can't wait to just have, uh, some of my best friends in the world visit me
and us just get to hang out again, because...god, you know, that's something that I missed doing being out here, but...
The opportunities that I get in LA are so great and I can never forget that
and I can't forget that I'm doing all of this, you know, for you guys.
You know, I really really really grateful for these opportunities.
I've mentioned him before and I've played a few games with him, but I do have a brother that does a webcomic called TwoKinds.
Now, my brother has been one of my biggest inspirations for pushing me to do something on my own
and, you know, I don't give enough credit to him, or promotion for his own website
so you can find a link to his webcomic down in the description if you don't know about it,
um, and he's just a really cool guy and he's one of the people that I miss the most being out here in LA,
um, it's just really hard because me and him were so close growing up, you know, we never fought,
you know, he's always been my very best friend and, you know, if I ever get married - I dunno when that's gonna be,
but, you know, he's always gonna be my best man, so...you know, I owe him a lot and I owe a lot of people a lot of things, so...
Uh, but anyway, I got - I got sidetracked there.
My brother's a really cool guy and I owe him a lot, that's all I'm trying to say.
But he runs a webcomic that published through this company called Red Giant Entertainment.
Now, Red Giant I've mentioned before because they were the ones who were really cool to both me and my brother,
uh, they're the ones who got him his own booth at Comic-Con,
San Diego Comic-Con, by the way, which I'm going to be at this uh, July
and uh, not only did they give him his own booth and feature him a lot,
uh, they gave me an exhibitor badge, which is something that the public can't get
and this was before I had, you know, any sort of the success I have now,
I think I had 2,000 subscribers when I went there and they still gave me an exhibitor badge,
and they treated me like I was, you know, royalty, they treated me super duper well and they were really cool to me.
They're just a really cool small company and so they asked me to help them out
because this Saturday is Free Comic Book Day.
So they're launching this line of free comics, and if you don't know what Free Comic Book Day is,
uh, you can look up, I think it's freecomicbookday.com, there's a link in the description, I don't know the website
but you can go there, you find your local, uh, comic book shop and if you go there,
you can get a whole bunch of free comics, so they asked me to promote these,
and I don't usually do promotions or trying to sell you guys things but,
this company's been really good to me, and these aren't exactly selling you anything because there is no catch
you just walk in, you ask for the comics and they give them to you for free
so, uh, here they are, they're launching eight different titles across four comic books,
so you can see they got, uh, this one called First Daughter,
Tesla, which I read and that was actually really cool,
uh, Dual Identity...Dark Haunt, and then you flip the side over and they got, uh, Shadow Children,
Pandora's Blog, uh, Wayward Sons which is another really cool one,
and Magika which is like a children's one, but it's really really well drawn, like,
I love the art in that one, that's absolutely fantastic.
Anyway, they're all free, they're all totally free, but I'm still trying to sell you something,
so I feel...dirty and disgusting about it, so I'm going to slap myself in the face!
Owie! Again!
Ow! (laughs)
Ow!
Ok, so anyway. That was just something I had to do because I-I really don't like to, uh, run promotions for you guys
but these guys have just been so cool to me, so, uh, this Saturday!
Check it out, the website to find your comic book shop, you can get these all for free,
and the cool things about these is these are the start of a different line so they'll always be free,
these actually aren't just free for Free Comic Book Day, these will ALWAYS be free.
You know, they're just running this thing, they're ad supported I think?
Kinda like YouTube, you get free entertainment but you have to watch an ad.
But it's just like, there's only like, two ads in there, so. It's pretty cool, either way.
Ow! (laughs)
Oh, speaking of slapping myself in the face, I've got another Impossible Let's Play coming up very soon
and it's got a very special guest and it doesn't involve physical pain!
Maybe! I don't know, we'll find out. Can't wait.
Alright, so that's all I'm gonna blab about for now, I think I have a red spot on my face,
so thank you guys so much for always supporting my videos,
like, just lately they've gotten the biggest response I've ever seen,
I think the hot sauce Impossible Let's Play is almost at 100,000 likes
and the closest I've gotten to that is like 50,000, like, it's unbelievable how much you guys have supported me,
especially through these really cool new things that I'm trying.
So thank you guys so much, I cannot wait for my friends to get here
and we can all hang out and make the coolest videos for you guys.
So thanks again for everything that you've done for me. And as always, I will see you in the next video.
Bye-bye!
(sings) Bye!